The answer is friends equals friends dot replace. Friend name and a space with
an empty string. We can look at an example to see how this works. So if this
person is Maria and this person is TJ. If we call Maria dot unfriend TJ, we'll
come into this method and we'll be doing it for this object. First thing that
happens is we call friends dot replace friend dot name with a space after it,
and then replace it with an empty string. Friends is initially TJ Jamesha. And
friend dot name, whoops, that's actually an error, it should be nonfriend dot
name. Do you think that's a compile time error, or a run time error? I'll just
fix it. So nonfriend, aas TJ dot name is the string with TJ and nothing else.
And then we're adding that together with another space. So we look for the TJ
space and friends, and we replace it with an empty string. So this creates a
new string, Jamesha with a space. And now we take that string and we make
friends, which again was Maria is friends. Stop pointing at TJ Jamesha, and
point at just Jamesha with a space.